when you meet Navy Seals is there a
certain like bond that you immediately
have it's actually funny I'll go to
airports and I'll literally spot one
seals are kind of all over the place
they're traveling a bunch and I remember
I was like at the airport in Atlanta and
I spotted a dude from like super crowded
terminal it was a quick glance never met
this guy in my life but I knew
immediately he was an ABC it's funny I
walked up to him and it wasn't like are
you it was like hey dude what team are
you on he's like oh I'm on this team
like cool man good to see you there's no
way I swear to God did he know who you
were he could tell that I also was a
seal when you become a Navy seal really
what you've done and what you've
demonstrated is you're able to hit
barriers mental physical and really I do
believe that virtually anyone can do
that but few people will do that if
you're someone that has pushed yourself
Beyond a certain boundary and you see
somebody else that you know and they've
done the same thing there's going to be
a kinship there there's going to be a
connection but definitely with Navy SEAL
specifically